hey this is the interview part of the
video can wikipedia help offline
reinforcement learning if you haven't
seen it i've made a comprehensive review
of this research paper in the previous
video so be sure to check that out the
authors that i speak to today are the
authors of this paper they've seen my
review and they're ready to dive in and
tackle all of my criticisms it's a big
privilege to have the authors on and to
be able to ask them any questions so
please let me know how i'm doing let me
know how i can improve these videos for
you and as always if you like leave a
like and i'll see you around
bye
[Music]
hi everyone today i'm here with michelle
reed and utaro yamada who are the
authors of the paper can wikipedia help
offline reinforcement learning first of
all uh both of you welcome and thank you
very much for being here and discussing
the paper with me thank you thanks for
inviting us so i i obviously you know
the the basic ideas of the paper i've
i've mentioned what what would interest
me is just um
how would you pitch the paper if you had
to pitch the paper let's say someone
comes up to you at a poster presentation
or something like this what would be
your initial pitch like whatever 30
second or a minute um the basics of what
you do
well i'll give it a shot ah let's see so
here
in our paper
uh we look at
seeing whether say wikipedia or language
free training
can help other sequence modeling tests
and in this case we focus on
offline reinforcement learning and i
found this to be personally like a
pretty cool project because essentially
um the reasons are not completely clear
to be honest uh but we see that with
this language region we can actually see
quite substantial gains in certain areas
um over
like regular like random random
initialization um and i think even more
interesting is that it
these models managed to converge faster
which shows that there is some sort of
information there that is helpful and
personally
i'm pretty interested in this line of
research because it really begs the
question like how are these seemingly
unrelated tests similar is there a way
to see how similar they are and maybe
even um encourage like a new paradigm
for transfer learning uh where you don't
even need like uh conventionally related
data how did you you mentioned it a
little bit why it's interesting and i i
completely agree and the results are
uh astounding i would say how did you
get the idea to do this because
initially if someone told me
you know you just pre-trained something
on language and then use it for
reinforcement learning or something like
this you'd
dismiss it quite quickly let's say of
all the ideas that you could choose from
so how did you like did you have some
indication that this could work or a
hunch or did you just try it at some
saturday morning like how how did it
come about uh sort of a mix of all three
so like to
like i guess as a background we have
that like say in multilingual learning
um it's been demonstrated by a couple of
papers now
that say you can transfer like an
english bird to a spanish
bird for example
or you can like add new languages to
to like say a model where it wasn't
pre-trained on those languages
or even there's like an experiment in
the embark paper i think where they
have like this application where they
pre-train on like six languages and then
they test
um on like some unseen languages if i
remember correctly and that works too so
like in the multilingual settings
um this sort of intuition has been
demonstrated though you could argue like
oh it's language to language
and then
i was talking with the other author
in this paper shane
uh one day we were just chatting and we
ended up talking about like pre-training
for rl and i was like oh there's no
pre-training for rrl um
like they haven't had like their burt
moment or their gpt moment yet
um and we're discussing um he was like
discussing the limitations
and then i was like why don't we try
doing a language model and then
yeah and then it became sort of like the
saturday morning experimentation session
uh which you like alluded to which is
like i was like that day i was like okay
let me just try putting the language
model there and see what happens and the
initial results uh were actually quite
surprising in a good way so we decided
to continue doing that oh i was gonna
just add on to like i remember you
marshall was saying that when when when
shen's first when shan's first reaction
was like there's no way that it's going
to work like
that
i don't think he was really excited
about the idea like when michelle
actually did experiments and showed the
results he was like really
yeah
exciting yeah
um you you
the basic concept here is i think it is
very simple and therefore the sort of
the setup of the paper is very simple
right you pre-train on this on this
language modeling objective and you make
a point that it is um the
auto-regressivity
might be
somewhat important right here in in what
you do and then there is this decision
transformer on the
on the right hand side
now
did i i don't know how much you've seen
of my introductory video but did i get
anything wrong in the setup here or did
you
did you want to highlight a specific
part of this like why could language
models be particularly useful for this
kind of reinforcement learning offline
offline reinforcement learning with
decision transformers right uh yeah i
think you captured it uh pretty well
um i guess like we'll go deeper into
like sort of maybe the reasons why this
could work as we go deeper into the
questions but like as like a high level
idea yeah i think you captured it pretty
well um i i was always just maybe as as
a side note i was always bit astounded
by these decision transformers by the
whole approach of of doing this as kind
of this sequence modeling uh with this
fixed context size and these returns to
go and then i just essentially i
essentially say well
i just want like a really high return
like just get me there um it seems it
seems very special but it seems to work
i don't know if you have any any
thoughts on this not necessarily related
to your your paper but i do find it a
very special model for for reinforcement
learning specifically
yeah
like for sure like actually i was
experimenting with like
um trying some higher turns i don't
think we included in the paper um but
sometimes like especially during early
stages of training you could like get
free returns almost
by just using like an artificially large
uh returns
um to go value and then suddenly like
the model would get better at the first
time
um for example so yeah this i think it's
pretty amazing honestly
um maybe shows
something about the power of
transformers to sort of like gather sort
of idea or ideas like states
um together and combine them in
interesting ways um you i think we can
directly go a little like into the
results uh because as i said the setup
is is quite simple
now you test on two different on two
different data sets so just to remind
people we have
uh the decision transformer which kind
of serves as the the baseline for what
we're trying to do that's sort of a same
model with the same technique and the
same inputs just not pre-trained on
language and then there is this am i
pronouncing this correctly chibi-t
model that is the same size but has been
pre-trained on language and then there's
gpt2 which is a lot larger and obviously
has been pre-trained on language and
then you have some some bass lines over
here that are just for offline
reinforcement learning now you can you
mentioned that your models consistently
outperform or the
language pre-trained models consistently
outperform the decision transformer but
one of my worries here was that the
standard deviations especially in this
experiment they seem they seem ginormous
um
this is their
like how can we be sure we're not just
measuring like it's better in the in the
bottom table right here but on this dqn
benchmark how can we be sure we're not
just measuring noise in these cases
i would say um well
we can't be sure
but i would i could say i would say that
like the trends across experiments
um do tend to like point towards a
certain direction
um and also like this was like i'm
generally like a language person
so when i was coming to rl and i was
saying oh wow we just changed the random
seed
and well it changed by this much it was
quite surprising to me um but after like
running experiments many times it seems
the trends were towards one direction
but i guess we could clarify that with
some like significance tests um yeah
like that i i was i was
i think i was mentioning that that the
trend is in in one direction i think
that's that's much more convincing than
you know anything being inside or
outside of some standard deviation what
surprised me also is that uh they're
just i think that's just a property of
reinforcement learning as such for
example this the q bert environment all
of a sudden you see for example there
are baselines that just fail like they
they just
nothing right and then all but all of a
sudden
these models also aren't as good but
then this model is really good like how
do you
and
also in the bottom table
i think a lot of times sort of which
model is better than which other model
is all over the place uh sometimes these
are better sometimes these are better do
you have an explanation of what's going
on here why is there such a let's say a
a diversity of which approach wins in
which circumstance
uh no um but i i would say uh this is
what is pretty interesting like i feel
now again i'm coming from like a
language perspective and i'm sure an rl
person could give you like a much better
explanation
uh but even when i was experimenting i
noticed like for some environment
the transformer tended to do like
like even early on like the language
pre-training tended to like
significantly better
um than the
say like the not language pre-trained
models or even like the other models we
have here and this is just honestly it's
my intuition but i feel like
some of these techniques are like very
um specialized or maybe like very
specialized to the sense that maybe we
don't know exactly what it is but there
are some properties of the environments
that
really go nicely with certain techniques
but then don't go nicely with certain
others and it's sort of like this random
sort of puzzle
um game that's being played here uh that
was my intuition when i was like playing
with it i was like oh wow this is this
is pretty weird actually
um but yeah that's that's my intuition
yeah obviously even when like if you
look like a
to a gbt columns i think it sort of
varies across the environment um as well
so i think that sort of
speaks to
i also feel in reinforcement learning a
lot of times these algorithms are
almost like designed with a problem in
mind um they they are formulated as
these general algorithms but i think a
lot of times people people go and they
see uh what's the problem i felt like
this you know like go explore that the
first algorithm that solved montezuma's
revenge right i looked at it and i was
like you just you just like essentially
hard-coded the game into the algorithm
even even with their they had two
versions even with their non
non-human designed feature space i'm i
was just like you you looked at
you know you looked at what fails and
you just hard coded a solution and you
just i'm trying to tell me that this is
a general maybe something like this is
happening here too where people they
analyze what goes wrong in particular
environments and then they make an
algorithm that
would specifically address those
problems i find this to be i find
reinforcement learning to be
an interesting field because of because
it seems like it's so not solved yet
um
when we just look at your models there
is a there is a discrepancy first of all
i've noticed that a lot of times the the
gpt-2 here doesn't
significantly sometimes it outperforms
but oftentimes it doesn't significantly
outperform the much smaller model um do
you have an
intuition as to maybe what's you know
why don't we see
a bigger benefit of large models here
it's you say somewhere it's uh over 100
times larger
uh my intuition is this so like i think
with like the certain papers we've shown
that like larger models can fit um
like larger amounts of data better uh
maybe we can even extrapolate from those
larger amounts of um data better but if
we think about what we're transferring
here and it's not again it's not
completely clear as of yet
but if we assume that it's say maybe a
smaller set of
features or properties rather than like
language as a whole but maybe like some
properties of language
then we can maybe say that okay if gbt
and gpt2 despite their like very
different sizes have learned sort of the
same sort of
maybe some element of the structure some
notion of hierarchy
or something like that and they're both
learned like relatively equally so to
say
um then maybe size doesn't matter as
much here given that uh we're
fine-tuning on this same like relatively
small
amount of like trajectory data
um so that's that's what
is it called
gbt because it sounds like gpt
no
um
because well it was sort of related um
but chibi like is means like sort of
small
mini okay um type of thing in japanese
so it was like a a joke
um because initially so initially i was
calling it gblm actually
uh like when i was just referring to
because i needed a name i couldn't write
like the small pre-trained language
model um every time
uh and then shane was like you know what
let's make it chibiti
so then that's that's what
you you mentioned that uh clip often it
performs a little bit worse and to note
you only you only use the text encoder
or sorry the text uh model from from
clip which is
an um a
a sequence model like the other ones and
also there is igpt image gpt that
performs a lot worse we can see it in
this table it just gets nowhere right
and um you had some hypotheses
do you want to maybe especially for for
the image gpt um
you
what what is your
hypothesis on why that is just kind of a
failure case yeah i think utara can
answer this one because he was like
master of running these experiments
yeah so well i think
um
the image struck like the structure
that's in the image like so image gpt is
trained on basically you can unroll
pixels um
from like from images
and i think the structure that's there
in the image is like a really different
um from the structure that you've seen
in language um
and
in a way that like like if you only have
a static image
and if you only have like a pixels up
there
it's really hard to even like group you
know which pixels grouped together into
a discrete like up like unit of objects
like you know discrete um
um i guess discrete objects so so that's
that um so first of all like gb igb or
image gpt um
sort of like has to figure out that sort
of like discreteness like
um before um it can actually has ability
to transfer to these um
uh rl settings where it has more
discrete structures yeah and
so yeah that's that's i think
one of the main reasons why uh the
current version of image pt
that are trained on static images are
not really uh
good at transferring from from their
domain to rl test and i think if we can
actually train uh
the sequential modeling or sequential
models for like a video data where um
it'll be much easier to extract um
these like uh discreteness because
because if you only look at images or
static images it's really
it's and if you don't have any prior
information about objects like it's
really hard to
extract you know object only from static
images but if you have a temporal
dimension if you have a video info of
information
then it becomes much easier to extract
those
these um
objects because you know if you look at
like a
frame t and frame t plus one if you look
at like uh
pixels that transform from t and t plus
one um you know there is a difference in
terms of perspectives
so that sort of gives you a strong hint
of strong q regarding like which which
pixels grouped together
um
and that's a really difference i think
that will make
eventually i think if you have if you
invest more into video
research and if the sequential modeling
in the video domain i think it will be
a really big difference um so that i
think i'm i'm really excited about like
the
um the um the future of
like a structural um
modeling that uses the videos and i'm
excited to see how the uh pre-training
model on the video will be transferred
to like a different
domain like rl
in the future and possibly
the um sort of the direction into vector
quantized models might also help a
little bit because uh not working on as
you say it's really hard to even get
what pixels belong together but if we
had more of token based approaches maybe
you know that could that could help
decouple from the pixel level just just
a bit but that's i guess that's just
speculation uh by me and one speculation
i also had was with respect to um your
alignment modules right here so you have
these you have these linear projections
that try to make the token embeddings of
the rl problem as close as possible to
the token embeddings that were seen
during language pre-training which makes
sense because you kind of get to reuse
let's say the the paths that are already
there for the language models in your
ablations you show that these it also
works without them which was good for me
to see because
sometimes
uh it's little things like this that
only makes stuff work
but
in you know there is a difference
between the distribution of language
tokens which is usually like a zip
distribution or some sort of very heavy
tailed uh but but you know sharp
distribution
and
image tokens which by construction tend
to be more
uniform
especially you know if you think like
pixels but also the vector quantized
models they're by design uniform
and with the rl
problem could it be that
it's it's also a matter of how the
tokens are distributed uh maybe the the
rl tokens are again more more zipfian
distributed and that's why it might fit
a lot better or did you investigate
the appropriateness of this how the
embeddings
uh look like
um so
no we did we didn't actually look into
how the embeddings looked like that was
like um we actually planned to do this
because i think
like personally i think it would be like
really cool for example if we found out
that it actually like these embeddings
turned into like a sentence
um or something like that
um but i do uh agree with your
hypothesis about
maybe like how the tokens are
distributed
or how frequent things are and i think
this also sort of relates to
sort of the structure in
language or like this natural tendency
to express things in a certain way and
you may want to express certain concepts
more often than others and then there's
also like sort of this conditional
nature like maybe only if this concept
appears which is represented by a
certain set of tokens then you want to
talk about this
um which in a sense you could say
mirrors
rl
or like just any like sort of activities
that you would do
versus image modeling um personally i
feel
it's it's cool like as a topic but i
also do feel it's very forced in a sense
it doesn't feel very natural to me if
that makes sense do you feel that there
are other
disciplines that would transfer well to
reinforcement learning i don't know if
you've thought about this you you do
include language and images so maybe you
thought of even other things there are i
don't know protein modeling genetic
sequences there's sound and so on do you
have any hypotheses or any plans to try
out other modalities
uh yes uh that we we do uh want to try
other things i think like some
interesting things like in addition to
what you mentioned could even be like
you could arg this isn't natural
language but it's usually grouped in
together with like the nlp community but
like code
for example
or even like testing out different
languages simpler languages
controlling for complexity really maybe
even music
i definitely think speech
could be something else to try as well
uh as utara alluded to video i think
there's so many things in sort of our
uh i don't know about say like daily
life but there are a lot of things
around us which sort of have like a
natural sequential nature of things and
it would be interesting to see if
somehow uh
especially in like a low data regime if
these things are able to transfer to
each other well and if they're like some
maybe underlying principles
uh or maybe like some like biases that
are learned uh that correspond to like a
large majority of sequential data or
maybe certain types of sequential data
and might also help us
like group sequential data types um
maybe learn learn more about how they
relate to each other
and i think if we were able to do that
then i think we'd be able to study this
even more in depth and maybe build
models based on those findings
it's a pretty special world right that
all our models converge
from all the different modalities that
even allow us to do things like this i
find it to be i find it to be very
special time uh because it would not
have been possible if all the image
models are conv nets right and and
all the all the speech models are
somehow fourier transform some things um
everything sort of converging to
transformers
i have some people might not like it but
it does enable sort of a bigger picture
on on what even what it means to process
data or you know
if if you if you want to look at it like
this
so these these attention plots right
here i found to be very interesting now
to be clear this you say this is on uh
hopper so this is one of these gym tests
one of these continuous control tasks uh
is this one particular sample or is this
like an aggregate over the data set or
how do we what is displayed here
so this is an attention mode basically
given given a single trick single one
okay let's see yeah single trajectory
um but we can we can assume it's kind of
representative of
um of kind of what happens in in general
so i have made a bunch of observations
here in my video which some of which you
also state in the paper for example this
structure of of three like the models
often looking back three steps back
which makes total sense because the
decision transformer input comes in
these tuples of three right and i'm i'm
gonna guess
if i want to predict the next return to
go it's probably very related to the
last one especially if the reward is
more sparse i i can just predict like
the same number again i'm going to be
correct most of the time and maybe the
same with actions
given that in the continuous control
frame by frame i don't want to switch my
action around
too much maybe right but
it's a pace to look mostly at these
things um what i found interesting is
the image gpt had a
sort of a of just a recency bias like it
just seemed to look just two or three
tokens uh back in time which i think
supports very well what you claimed that
image modeling might be different from
language modeling in that
yeah it might be that the image
transformer just sort of looks at a
local neighborhood and then just goes on
doesn't care too much about big
structure and it's just hypotheses and
then i think the most shady thing i said
was with respect to the random randomly
initialized decision transformer so this
this would be the baseline model a
transformer that from scratch is trained
on this rl data and
i claimed what we can also see this sort
of pattern of three but much more
strongly than in something like gpt2
which does have have a more diffuse
attention so here it's really super
duper hard attention and i claim that
might
that might hinder the model from
learning
proper connections between things in the
future because it already kind of
discards in the early layers everything
that would connect uh sort of a state
and a reward is this
is this does this come close to what you
concluded or do you have like different
insights into these attention maps or
what's happening here
oh it's actually very very close to uh
what we were thinking after looking at
these attention maps i think one thing
actually after watching uh your video
that i didn't really notice until you
pointed it out was like
those yellow blocks of two
i didn't actually notice that they were
actually two
um
uh which i think is actually pretty cool
uh to see like maybe it though like for
those ones it weights
uh like two of them together maybe with
different weightings but overall i think
the interesting thing is that it's
pretty consistent
um like it doesn't necessarily change
like the patterns don't change
significantly
which is sort of unlike language for
example
where
you can see things like generally there
is a recency bias to some degree
but you can see things like depending on
the token
uh go like like pretty far if it's like
attending the similar tokens from far
back but then again
if you do think about it that way you
could argue like action
representations would probably be
similar to action representations state
to state representations and so on
so maybe actually the language models
and even the randomly initialized model
are mirroring uh
yeah it's i found it to be very special
how hard the attention patterns are is
right here but also there is always in
distance of three rows there is one that
is just only looking at three steps back
and six and nine and so on and then the
ones in between there is one that has as
you say that has two and one that even
has like it seems like almost it has
three but just one is a bit stronger
it'd be interesting to figure out which
one is which i i i don't think i can
tell from this thing but yeah
so i think the one that's only looking
at like three before
um if i remember correctly is the
returns to go
um and then the ones between that are uh
the say the state representations and
then the action
yeah so the order is basically word
state okay
yeah that makes makes a bit of sense and
we i think
the
sort of the result right here i think in
the middle layer it's really nicely
shown that something like gpt it will
start to focus on maybe kind of the
important things in the past i will
select some of them
to focus on
and
so no matter which time step it will
kind of look back at
maybe what it determines to be important
states
where as the randomly initialized one it
will almost be like stuck
in this mode of how it looks back
and
my so my question here and and you can
clearly see it in the last layer in that
in gpt
2 there's still this sort of focus and
attention on maybe what what it
determines to be important things in the
episode and the other ones they just
have like a diffuse
attention matrix and my question would
be
um
might it be possible that we could
achieve the effect between let's say
gpt2 and the random one like this this
benefit through
a much simpler procedure of just kind of
regularizing
just saying like you know don't make
your attention so hard like make you
know just kind of keep your options open
um try to look back a bit further don't
don't try to be so sure yet is that you
know is that something that's reasonable
or do you think uh there's reason to to
discard that idea
i think it's i think it's reasonable to
try um
but i still do feel that i think the
if we do something like this then maybe
we again fall into the trap of
what we were like talking about earlier
is like this essentially like putting a
band-aid
uh on like a very specific um
problem per se but i think like the cool
thing about transformers is uh they can
learn a lot of different things so i
think
if
you say like with a language model for
example it's
um it's an initialization you can
fine-tune it however you'd like to
and i think it's more like flexible in
that sense
um unless like say we were trying to
tackle like a very specific issue then i
think yeah it would be for sure
something to try
um like i think there's this recent
paper for language mumbling
uh by like ophea press
from uw and he
they were looking at like say how they
can bias uh the like basically enforce a
recency bias
uh towards a language model and that
like improves like extrapolation towards
longer sequences
uh and so on so i think in the in this
case in language modeling it's like one
specific task
um that they're trying to solve but here
if we like just talk about like offline
reinforcement learning
uh
it's very very broad and i think
um for example if you tried like ophir's
trick in
uh like say for pre-training bert or
something like that now again this is
just conjecture but i have a feeling it
may not work as well
um given like there's uh
i would say a lesser like um there was
also another paper by
i don't know who it was but i think from
dante chan's group at princeton recently
um about like uh the masking rate in
bert models and things like that and
perplexity doesn't necessarily correlate
uh with downstream performance and so on
um so yeah if we're tackling specific
tasks i would say sure but i think the
one nice thing about the language model
pre-training is how flexible it can be
yeah i was um i mean i was the same uh
i'm probably as you say falling in the
same trap that i criticized the field of
reinforcement learning say you know
looking at one thing and saying can i
make up something that would that would
just solve this one thing uh yeah and i
think you know the differences also to
clip uh show a little bit um that it's
not it's not just i can't just do
um any architecture or anything there
might actually be something to to
language modeling
uh
in this table you specifically show that
the
the um language model pre-trained ones
converge faster and i had one question
here and that was that is how different
is this code base like how much how much
of the difference in convergence can i
attribute to um you just being better at
implementing stuff and how much is
really due to
this these two things being pre-trained
is it the same code base or did you
re-implement or implement from scratch
i wish i could say i was like this
amazing programmer that can make things
so much more efficient but no
unfortunately
okay okay so yeah so this is legit legit
speed up that that is due to the
pre-training
nice
um i guess like one caveat that um
mentioned like about gpt2
is that the faster training speed is due
to like faster conversions
um even though like it's pretty even
though it's pretty big but like say
um when like you're doing like your
rollouts um and stuff like that
inference time it is definitely like
slower as to be expected by a larger
model yeah that makes makes sense i was
also surprised because in reinforcement
learning usually the conventional wisdom
is that it needs a lot of resources and
here you you mentioned something like
you know you have a single v 100 and the
time here is i mean even for the
decision transformers it's a couple of
hours it's not it's not i have to train
on eight gpus for a couple of days i was
just positively surprised by by uh just
sort of the the requirements and this
makes it more accessible
yeah i think that's the cool thing about
offline rl um you just
well you just have to like say fit a
certain set of trajectories
um and there have been like a lot of
pretty efficient uh models recently as
well
so yeah i think it's when you get into
the online setting then things get um
pretty like computationally expensive um
you also mentioned that context size
doesn't really matter in fact more
context seems to make stuff worse a
little bit right
like how significant this really is um
but do you have
an idea here is that is it just because
there's more noise um or is there
something wrong with the objective of
the decision transformer
i think um partially more noise and two
i think
because of like say the tasks that are
tested in gym
um
it's like you see a cheetah running for
example or you have like this upper
which is literally just hopping
um and that those
those emotions are relatively repetitive
um like in atari for example the context
uh is i think quite a bit larger
um
i i don't remember exactly what the
value was but maybe like 50 uh or maybe
even a bit bigger than that
um
but it's like okay for atari maybe you
need more information because i guess
like the actions that are being
performed are more diverse
um and like sort of what can happen is
more diverse but then for these tasks um
then maybe in that much context is not
as necessary
this is just my intuition maybe an rl
person would be able to give a better
idea of why
um so the the last thing that that was
here very special is just the scaling
behavior of this of these models namely
the with the language model pre-training
uh you could scale to much larger models
do you have a feeling of how that
continues like does it does it continue
dropping off and just not giving you
returns anymore or would it eventually
also say you have like a model that's
too large
and
it would drop in performance again
versus a smaller model because my
hypothesis was that
language modeling you have infinite data
essentially so you can never over fit on
the pre-training um and therefore you
know the there might never be really an
opportunity to over fit
on a a fine-tuning data set i don't know
do you have an intuition i'm going to
guess
you know maybe you didn't want to go up
to two high parameter models
uh yeah for like computational reasons
um but
uh for but i do generally agree with you
like if we have i think if we have a
decent initialization
um like from the like language we're
going to say like like going for like
infinite data
um then i think
we should be able to
arguably at least retain the same
performance or get like very close to it
um
there perhaps there is a time like a
point where it just gets too big
um that it starts overfitting but i
would say that would probably happen
when it like not not close to the the
parameters we tested by now use oh so
also i think oh yeah sorry
so like one thing
one good thing about like offline arrows
so you can also collect a lot more um
trajectory data from just running agents
and
and then training offline data so i
think um there's that perspective and in
this in this figure um
like we can also train like a larger
model and on larger
trajectory data and then if you have
like a really good language
initialization then you can also try
that sort of direction also i think in
the future do you have an idea how that
trades off like would i rather would i
rather
invest into pre-training my model on
language data or would i rather invest
into gathering more offline rl data
personally i think
if you're working with a fixed like say
okay say if we fix the amount of offline
rl data
um and say we're gonna like use that
versus like designing like a better
algorithm or something i would say
pre-train your language model um but
then again as we see with the like tpt
versus gpt experiment
making it that much bigger like sure it
does help like by advice um some margin
but it's not like that super significant
um so based on that if we're going to
assume that language transfers only like
a certain set of maybe limited
properties to
these rl tasks
then i would say yeah collect more
rl data i would say you
said at the beginning you tried it out
you thought about it it it kind of
worked out of or initially you got some
promising results was there ever a thing
that
didn't work like like the
something in this project you tried and
just didn't work at all or it didn't
work at first uh any sort of avenues you
got stuck in i would say that what was
interesting
uh was that the cosine
the cosine loss that we added uh
especially like towards uh like later
stages everything sort of smooths out
but this more has to do with uh how fast
the model converges so that's actually
maybe we should have ablated this but
the cosine loss actually allows the
world to converge much faster
and
uh one thing that was interesting is
especially in the early stages that the
cosine
so say we weren't using the cosine
embedding loss initially and we just saw
like gpt and gpt achieving and tbt was
like quite a bit lower
than gpt but then like say gpt without
this extra loss and then tbt with the
loss gbt managed to catch up to gpt
which is like pretty mind-blowing to me
um so like something like that was
interesting i wouldn't say like a hiccup
because it actually worked like pretty
well
uh like straight off the bat but
uh it was pretty interesting to see and
another thing was
um without
say like the positional embeddings for
example
um
i would you would general like i think
we ablated this but we would generally
see like quite uh lower
uh returns um and things like that so
maybe even like the position transferred
from language is also quite important um
is there is there anything else you'd
like to get out about this paper uh can
people can people get into this
themselves uh your your code is it
available
yeah uh so actually it's in the footnote
uh of the first page
um
so yeah i think uh this stuff personally
is super interesting uh to see how we
can transfer different sequence
modeling tests to each other sort of
unites like say one big
big model that handles all the sequences
uh or something like that another thing
that was actually pretty cool is with
like the language modeling code training
that we did
um
when we did it the language like it was
that we actually had a model that was
able to languish model and was able to
handle trajectories at the same time and
like the language only performance
didn't degrade significantly
which was also pretty cool
because it means that because we
essentially have the capacity even at a
small scale
to do both of these tasks
at once
and if we have like these models that
are able to handle these separately um
then it begs the question okay what can
we do together um
like can we model everything all
together like basically i think
with
um what was it the like say like with
multilingual pre-training
um that we have it's sort of like until
i guess ever or maybe like a few papers
before that
we didn't really feed old uh languages
just together at once and see what
happens and then on top of that we see
like oh we have like this zero shot
transfer uh whether it's truly zero shot
is a different question but still it's
pretty cool
um
and i think if we can sort of replicate
that
uh say we have
um like i don't know a remotely related
language modeling uh like a domain and
language and if we fine tune on this
domain and language suddenly we can do
like trajectory modeling on this domain
that say has to do with what was talked
about in language and things like that
like it opens a new set of possibilities
for maybe like generalization
um and just like zero zero shot well
i don't like using that word but like uh
that
photo performance in general like these
new behaviors and stuff cool excellent
well um michelle in in utara thank you
very much for being here and sharing
sharing the projects i hope to see you
again very soon um with more more
modalities and
and uh more
i think this is i i'm still i'm still uh
amazed sort of by by the results i find
them really cool and yeah good luck in
the future
[Music]
you